thank you good evening welcome to the
standards committee meeting of the 29th
march 2022
agenda item number one apologies for
absence we have apologies from
councillor mrs june lamley
and mr s shadbolt
are there any other apologies
there are none
agenda item number two substitute
members
there are no substitute members
gender item number
three non-members attending
uh councillor our mr arthur williams
portfolio holder for community has
joined us tonight we also have guests
from brentwood borough council
we have amanda amanda julian corporate
director legal and governance and
monitoring officer
and our other guest is claire mayhew
also from
brentwood borough council corporate
manager democratic
services
good evening councillor mrs cohen
agenda item number four
minutes of the meeting held on the 29th
of june 2001
are the minutes agreed members
agreed
thank you
gender item number five to request to
receive declarations of interest are
there any declarations of interest
please members
there are none
gender item
number six local investigations and
determinations
from april 2021
to september 2021 and also
october 2021 to march 2022
our monitoring officer angela law will
present this report
thank you chairman
um as
as usual this is a summary of complaints
and queries received in relation to
members behaviour under the code of
conduct
um
usually this report is received twice
yearly however given that
um we the the last commit standards
committee meeting was cancelled it this
appendix um one contains the whole
year's complaints you'll see that there
are
seven in total and i'm happy to take any
questions there may be for members thank
you members uh councillor mr mike
wilkinson please
thank you sir
is that working yes good um through your
chair for me um
just to to angela this is my first
meeting with the standards committee so
forgive me because i have seen this
report before
but i can't remember what was in it um
one thing that struck me from this was
out of the seven complaints at least
five if not six of them actually there's
no breach under the code
and i wonder if that's such a training
issue for members that actually for
those
not trying to sway people for making
complaints because obviously that's
their they're right but
maybe there's a misunderstanding of what
does pull within the code and what
doesn't and i don't know if that's
something's being looked at thank you
angela
the um
it's not necessary training issue um
some of the complaints are actually
from um members of the public so unless
i can train all members of the public it
is very hard to you know i would assume
that we're internal sorry no no no this
um if it if it assists um in the future
i can add another column to say whether
it's a member of the public or whether
or or i could just remember the puppy
and leave it at that so um yeah not all
not all the complaints are internal
actually i think most of them are
members from members of the public who
obviously don't really understand um the
technical side of the code
i think that's a very good point that um
counselor mr um wilkinson
raised um
could you add that quality yes because i
think that would help members members
agree
yeah um councillor robin dre please
um thank you chairman um i just wanted
to
remind members that uh under the members
code of conduct which is in the
constitution that it does include
members
and counsellors activities on social
media
in addition there is
guidance given to councillors in respect
of the use of social media
and i've asked the monitoring officer
if
a copy of that guidance can be resent to
all councillors
thank you chairman
yes chairman um i can certainly
send out the uh social media policy to
all members
um
the policy is there designed to assist
members when using social media policy
and it talks about the freedom of
expression as well so
you will see there are a couple of
complaints where
it was about their behavior on social
media but no breach was
found um so
given given now that we're in powder it
might it might be useful to uh reissue
that to all members so i'll ensure that
happens
thank you madam chairman um one other
point is obviously the code of conduct
members code of conduct um refers to
members having respect for each other
and obviously that again extends to
uh having respect for each other on
social media
thank you the um media social media
policy will
deal with that
thank you
councillor mr daniel fd
thank you chair
um
we get this report and it just comes up
with
nothing to be taken or no breach of code
of conduct
doesn't seem to be any
how
you come to that
decision it's not known like when you
used to be in school there's no like how
you show your workings out
is that
something
maybe especially with um
the social media stuff a lot of these
seems to be social media on here
and
but all of them
no further action or it hasn't or not
understand code not understanding the
code of conduct i understand what you're
saying if it's members of the public
putting this through
um
don't quite
no
it seems to be a big jump from when you
get the complaint to when you get
what's actually going to happen there's
no nothing for us to see
so chairman uh counselor are you asking
for more detail yeah yeah
yes that's i mean i can put more detail
in there but obviously i would not like
to because there's no further action on
this
wouldn't want to start
giving too much detail which gives away
who the counselor is and who the
complainant is so do you get back to the
complainant like why there's no why
there's no further action i don't i
don't notify i will
look at it i'll tell the complainant why
there's no further action so
and i consult with independent person
i don't usually and i probably actually
i don't consult with the
subject of complaint because if it
doesn't go anyways it it
it makes that
rocks the relationship between the
complainant and the
um
the subject of complaint
so and and also if there's a future
complaints come forward
you know they know they'll know that
there's been a complaint in the past and
you know i don't want vexatious
complaints to start building
okay so
if you feel there's no there's there's
no action to be taken you don't really
inform the person the complaints being
made
about
sometimes it
like i said it just um it just
hinders the relationship between
the subject complaint and the
complainant who's making the complaint
okay
thank you
i i don't think members like to be told
that this complaint against them and
it's just
sometimes it can get too personal
if if it doesn't go any further as the
complainant
themselves are told exactly why
the counselor hasn't breached the code
and why the complaint doesn't go any
further and usually that ends the matter
okay thank you thank you
members are there any other questions
counselor mrs tony carter please thank
you chair and angela can i just ask you
is there an appeals panel um or is there
an appeals after this your decision is
final my decision is final it is okay
thank you
thank you any other questions members
no there are none so members there's a
recommendation to paragraph 4.1 on page
6.1 of the report
the recommendation is that the summary
of complaints and determinations for the
period
april 2021 to march 2022
be received is that received memphis
agreed thank you
moving on agenda item number seven
safeguarding training
louise moss is here tonight our
assistant director for people and
communities who will present this report
thank you chair
so the purpose of this report is to ask
this committee to consider whether to
mandate level one safeguarding training
for all councillors
the reason for this is detailed in the
report
but principally and predominantly it's
to ensure a whole organisational
approach to safeguarding in fact it's
everyone's responsibility at all levels
and it shows continuing commitment
against our policy
the level one training as detailed in
the report is a very basic awareness
training
and it is going to be virtual so
hopefully that also allows accessibility
to the training
it doesn't detail this in the report but
it will only be 30 minutes and some
counsellors around this table would have
experienced that training already
and we are proposing that it's annual
and i would say that the training if you
have experienced the training already is
a very localized training session as in
it takes
examples of safeguarding concerns and
issues
that have been experienced by officers
and possibly members and allows officers
and members to visualize it easily
and determine the best course of action
from it so i'll leave that for the
committee and any questions please do
let me know
thank you councillor mr fd
thank you chairman
i think this is a really great idea
every counselor should have safeguarding
training because when you're out and
about visiting residents you need to
stop and think sometimes before you do
something but the only question i've got
looking at making this mandatory how
would we enforce it
because if they don't turn up it goes
there's no committee or anything you can
stop them sitting on like development or
anything like that so
[Music]
that i think that's where it might fall
down a little bit
um
council lefty just um the answer is
probably within the legal implications
of the report um although we can't make
it a legal requirement for mandatory
training obviously if you do agree that
it should be mandatory then obviously
the enforcement of it will be through
the influence of group leaders
sorry council left if i can just add to
that it is through the um group leaders
but i think from a group point of view
reputationally it doesn't look too good
on the groups if if some of their
members do not pretend
[Music]
thank you um counselor um angelina maria
please
how are you going
paris
yeah um
just one moment
counselor mr fd is quite correct just
need to
have a microphone around here
thank you
right how did how do you involve
parishes
and also
is there a cost involved to us because
sometimes with regard to our dc training
in the past for various courses
there has been a cost beyond one or two
complementary places
and yet i'll answer that just to confirm
there would be no cost and training
would be offered as normal route so as
and when training is offered to
councillors it would be opened up to all
parishes at that time thank you
thank you are there any other questions
members
um i would like to say um totally agree
with um councillor uh mr fd's comments
um
fully support this um what i would like
to see is is there the opportunity
for members to also do level 2
training
with regard
to the parish council
councillors i'm pleased that it will be
offered to all
as
they're really our front line often who
are meeting the residents um on a
continuous day-to-day basis and that
there's no cost
perhaps um
members parish members who are here can
take this back and
encourage other parishes
to send their members along so um yet
just back to my first question is there
the opportunity level two please
there is opportunity to do level two and
beyond that there's a certain amount of
free training and e-learning training as
well through the asset safeguarding
adults and children's board and i'm very
happy to share that information to
councillors should they want to progress
with level two thank you
okay members um there is one
recommendation at paragraph 9.1
on page 7.3 of the report that level 1
safeguarding training is made mandatory
for all elected members
can those members in favor please raise
their hands
thank you very much members that is
unanimous
and that concludes our meeting for the
evening members thank you very much
for coming along this evening thank you